hello everyone I'm back with another
game from day one this is from round
three which marathon Island is playing
against Peter lake oh and a lot of play
a lot of people are saying that this is
the greatest game played in day one but
they may that may or may not be so that
is open for discussion I guess but not
only did I don't play a brilliant game
against Lake oh here he played all five
games
excellent and with three wins and two
draws after five rounds
he is currently in seventh place with
four points or in a shared third place
whichever you prefer but that being said
let's let's see this game Island has the
white pieces and again we have efore so
a lot of ephors in this world rapid
championship lakeville goes for e5
Knight to f3 knight c6 and Bishop to c4
detail in game Bishop to c5 we have
castles and Knight to f6 d3 castles h3
b6 this is all standard theory c3 a6 a
for preventing b5 Bishop to a7 we have
Knight B to d2 unites the e7 and rook to
e1 c6 now may be preparing to push d5 or
b5 Bishop to b3 not allowing to push d5
or b5 with tempo also preparing to
Riemann over the bishop to c2 from there
the bishop will help help guard the
center and also maybe maybe later it
will become an attacking piece when it
will be able to reach age 7 9th to g6 we
have better up to c2 immediately a rook
to e8 and d4 Knight to h5 and now we
have night 2 f1 preparing Knight g3 or F
or e3 it depends on what black plays
Knight H to f4 and night the g3 now eek
after Sundy for C capture Sun d4 and d5
and this is the first inaccuracy by Lego
here he played d5 and allowed on earth
to push 'if I've now I mean the bishop
becomes alive also the bishop on c1 is
also pretty good instead of this d5 idea
after seek after sandy for a better
approach would actually be c5 now if you
capture them two queens come off the
board the dark
where bishop becomes active but if an
ant pushes d5 then his own light square
bishop isn't that powerful and this this
pawn structure would would black would
enjoy this pawn structure much more than
the one after seek after some before and
the d5 but okay Allen place a 5 we have
c5 now but now it it seems it's a bit
too late
anna plays Bishop captures on g6 we have
Knight captures on g6 and Bishop to g5
would attempt on the Queen Knight to e7
is played and Queen to d2 now and here
there are there are a lot of possible
moves here for black but actually none
of them are very good probably the best
move for black would be something like
King to h8 but even realizing that
you're already in a in a bad position as
black here isn't isn't very easy
especially in rapid chess so in this
position like who played h6 and this is
where Anand really really goes all out
he plays Bishop to f6 possible was also
Bishop captures on h6 leading to a lot
better position for white but okay
Bishop to f6 by Anand and aleko plays
King to h7 the idea behind the G
captures on f6 is a pretty wild one if
GK afters on f6 then the simple Queen h6
Knight to a5 and now Knight captures on
f5 Bishop captures an f5 and now he
captures on f6 the threat is now of
course Queen to g7 checkmate and after
rook captures rook captures and Queen to
f8 to defend checkmate simply Queen to
g5 if you move the King you lose the
bishop on f5 so Bishop to g6
and now rook to e7 and there really are
no moves here for black white is white
is threatening Knight e5 followed by
Knight captures on g6 and this is game
over you can't even stop it with rook to
e8 in hopes of exchanging works because
again Knight to e5 and after rook
captures pawn captures you have to where
you have to guard the queening Square
after plague Queen to d8 - really
anything to win here Knight g4 with the
threat of Knight to f6 a check for King
the king and the Queen and now you
really are without a move if you move
the Queen simply white gets the Queen
which check you capture and Knight to f6
Forbes the king in Queen this is winning
and if you try something like King to g7
to prevent this then then then the same
between h6 check is checkmate into King
g8 and Knight to f6 this is checkmate
so after this Bishop to have six like oh
the clients the bishop place came to h7
but it's this isn't any better Knight to
g5 immediately by Anand checking the
King and again what's the idea here if
you capture the knight H captures night
then you get Queen captures on g5 again
the threat is Queen captures and g7
checkmate there is simply too much too
much threats here on the dark squares
alecko's dark square bishop is trapped
there on a7 can't really come and help
so after something like G captures and
it captures again there's a threat of
Queen to g7 checkmate ninth to five
simply Knight captures and after rook
captures would you check recap % Queen
to f8 Queen to f8 this is the only move
as White was threatening not only Queen
g7 checkmate
but also some Queen to h6 followed by g7
checkmate so Queen Queen to f8 prevents
both of these attacks but now simply
rook to e8 and black is without a move
you're gonna lose the Queen the next
move and then the move after that is
gonna be checkmate
so after this Knight to g5 check by
Anand aleko plays King to g8 and now
Alan brings another piece into the
attack
Knight to h5 and this is just H captures
and g5 doesn't work pretty much because
of the same reasons and of course now
there's an additional attacker here so G
captures on f6 capturing the bishop here
is really the only move so G captures on
f6 we have Knight captures on f7 now and
this this is beautiful
this comes with a tempo on the Queen the
queen is ready to jump to each
there is really no no good move other
than to capture the night king
characters on f7 and now Queen captures
on h6 we have Knight to a5 discounts
with an attack on the Queen Queen to h7
check now King goes to f8 and and now
comes he captures on f6 Bishop to Bishop
to e6 and we have Knight to f4 here and
this comes with a terrible threat of
knife to g6 aleko plate Queen captures
on f6 and now Knight to g6 check the
King has no squares all the squares are
covered only move here is to capture the
night Alec was forced to capture it wink
a person g6 Queen captures on g6 and if
you look at this position okay black
does have three pieces for the Queen but
the King is wide open and f8 it's gonna
be impossible for for like.oh to do
anything in this position Knight to g7
was played
now comes Luke to e3 and if aren't
played instead of rook to e3 if you
played rook to a3 this would have been a
lot faster as it's better for this rook
to stay on the e-file with rook to a3
falls by f3 it would have been over much
faster but most of all both moves are
winning doesn't really matter
rook to e3 we have rook to e7 preparing
to double up on the e-file rook a to e1
now and the doubles up on the e-file
rook 88 rook to g3 we have rook to f7 h4
now preparing h5 and h6 Bishop to b8
getting that Bishop that was trapped on
a 7 back into the game now rook G 2 e 3
back rook F to e7 back and now he
captures on c5 simply grabbing a pawn I
mean why not
Bishop to f7 would attempt on the Queen
Queen Queen to f6 now rook captures rook
captures rook captures pawn captures and
Bishop to c7 now aleko has three pieces
for the Queen the rooks are off the
board
but here comes g4 and those pawns are
really very hard to stop knight to e8
good attempt on the Queen Queen checks
on h8 Bishop to g8 and now comes h5
and here is Legos last try hell and it's
it's a really sneaky try Lego plays
Bishop to d8 and he's hoping he's hoping
for unand to blunder the game by playing
h6 and the prepared h7 to win the bishop
but I finally played h6 this would have
actually cost on to the game because
after Bishop to f6 Islands Queen and h8
is strapped so this was have been very
unfortunate for the former world
champion but after Bishop to d8 and on
simple plate Queen to h6 checked in IG 7
now comes Queen d6 check Bishop Bishop
e7 Queen B a check Knight blocks now
simply be for a5 simply Queen captures
b7 a captures Queen captures 936 and we
have Queen to f4 check King g8 and out
comes c6 and after Bishop to e6 and h6
in this position Peter like Oh resigned
the game there are simply too many pawns
you can stop all of them the H pawn is
becoming the Queen very soon the C pawn
is also very close the a pawn is pretty
much unstoppable so there's really no
point in continuing this there was some
maybe some merit to continuing the
position while the roofs were still on
the board
maybe maybe trick on and into you know
worsening his position but since he
didn't he did no such thing
it's it's pretty fair to resign in this
position so yeah definitely a beautiful
game and you know quite be attacking
quite the attacking style sounds almost
like a like Anand was 30 years younger
when they when they still called him the
lightning kid when he crushed everyone
you know in blitz rapid and in any time
control really so what do you think
about the game is it is it the best game
of day one and you know maybe maybe fee
they should consider bringing back the
brilliant surprise into tournaments and
you know offering offering something
along with the brilliant surprise you
know some money some fame I guess maybe
50 additional elope points you know and
anything but
definitely would give players something
something to fight for
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check to my
previous videos here and I think they
too already started so I'm gonna go
check out if there are any any
interesting games in day 2 already
season